and jordan how do you manage to keep
your head when all around you are losing
this
well it isn't self-evident that i did
you know i mean first of all battles
pick you much as you pick them
maybe more you know when i made the
first video i made
i was playing around with youtube i put
my lectures on youtube i had a little
bit of experience with tv in
ontario you know so i was dabbling
and i didn't know what youtube was
neither did anybody else
you know i didn't know it was going to
be the world's biggest television
network by an order of magnitude
i thought it was a place for cute cat
videos
it still is to be fair yeah well fair
enough you know
maybe that says something positive about
people too
so but i got swept up and
you know it's in many ways it's been
absolutely devastating
so now i made
i decided a long time ago that i was
going to say what i thought
you know that i was going to try to
orient myself and i think i had
experiences that were similar heather
said something very interesting you know
that she's
much less misanthropic than she might
have been had she not been a teacher
a caring teacher well you know the
spirit that animates our social
institutions is a lot more
in the nature of caring teacher with
deviation than it is
power hungry tyrant i really believe
that
i mean and you have to be
extraordinarily cynical not to see at
least
some of that and so the people i've
known that were
competent in their positions incompetent
institutions
were mentors who encouraged
and that's a good relationship to have
with people and it's the opposite of the
arbitrary expression of power and it's
something you do
both of you the mentor and the mentee
let's say the teacher and the student
you do that in the service of a higher
ideal and i've never met anyone that i
admired who exploited their students who
considered that a power i mean i've met
professors who
didn't put their graduate students names
on research
papers or were stingy about credit
but it's not like they were thriving it
just doesn't work
so when when do you stay silent well i
you stay silent
until the weight of having to lie is
worse than
the danger of speaking
and i'm not fond of deceptive
silence or outright lies i in my
clinical practice i never
ever ever ever saw
anyone get away with anything
and so that was horrible it's horrible
to think that that's true
it's true you think you got away with it
you just don't know the causal chain
that led to your demise
so you know that plus my understanding
too that
one of the factors that sustained and
generated
totalitarian atrocity was the
willingness of ordinary people to
swallow things they
knew to not be true
that was insisted upon by the
sophisticated observers of totalitarian
states that i found
most influential you swallow enough lies
your state becomes a monster
and so you know i've upgraded myself
continually for
bringing the chaos of the world into my
nice tight tidy little family
and it's been terrible but you know in
my defense i would say
i'm trying to stave off something worse
and if you think that it can't get worse
that just means
you don't know anything
so yeah joe you know it's up to
everybody in their conscience
you know and i think it's a matter of
figuring out what to be afraid of
i'm more afraid of silence and lies